so first rule of being a prosecutor
don't ask questions you don't know the
answer to
actually let me rephrase there's a rule
before that don't bring a prosecution
that is so bad that your prosecution
looks like the defense case that would
be the actual first rule the second rule
is don't ask a question you don't know
the answer to the prosecution in the
kyle were in house case decided to
violate both of those rules there was no
evidence that kyle rittenhouse
murdered anybody on that night in
kenosha wisconsin the self-defense case
is absolutely crystal clear it is clear
from the footage it is clear from the
testimony
every time somebody testifies on behalf
of the prosecution within about 35
seconds they're now testifying on behalf
of the defense and that's precisely what
happened in rittenhouse's trial
yesterday you remember the case of kyle
rittenhouse
in wisconsin he went to kenosha
wisconsin because there'd been a bunch
of riots there weren't enough police
officers there he went to provide
medical aid to people there's he's on
video discussing this he went to defend
essentially car lots from from being
burned up by by rioters and then he was
caught alone by a bunch of antifa thugs
he was chased they threatened him a shot
was fired in the air somebody was
lunging for his gun he shot them then he
ran away because the riot started to
follow him again
and then he was attacked by a man with a
skateboard tried to bash him in the head
shot that guy and then there was another
person who approached and uh and tried
to jump on him and beat him and he shot
that person uh and the and that person
who tried to jump on him
wasn't actually trying to jump i was
trying to shoot him okay so
that's pretty obvious self-defense it's
pretty obvious from all of the available
tape and all of the available testimony
and from the get-go we knew that the
people who engaged in the violence with
written house
were near due wells at the very best
okay most of them actually were just
terrible
criminals as it turns out and one of the
people who was shot was an actual sex
offender
another person who was shot
and did not die
was pretty obviously an antifa member he
admitted that he was affiliated with a a
group called the people's revolution
which is a communist militia group
that his gun permit had expired that he
had lied to the police shortly after the
shooting
and uh and that he himself is
financially
rewarded essentially if rittenhouse is
found guilty
it's all really really ugly stuff so one
of the clips here is just
incredible
okay so
it's it's it's unbelievable actually
so he's an antifa quote unquote medic
he was carrying a gun
in 2016 he was found guilty of breaking
wisconsin's law governing the use of
dangerous weapons her milwaukee county
court records and guns were armed while
intoxicated
he had received tickets for minor
offenses including disobeying police
officers making loud noises
and again he was deeply associated with
this antifa group
well
things got very ugly for him on the
witness stand yesterday
when he was asked specifically about
when he was shot
because the theory of the prosecution
based on
not only no evidence but like counter
the evidence is that written house shot
this person engaged gross crudes
that he shot him for no reason at all
and that he was not acting in
self-defense here is great gauge gross
cruz admitting
admitting that he was shot while
attempting to shoot kyle written house
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him with your gun now your
hands down pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
okay and if you actually had the rest of
this clip you would see that the
prosecutor puts his head in his hands
i mean he actually gets up and he shouts
directed verdict which means
a directed verdict is where you say that
the prosecution not only does not have
the evidence to prove its case but that
it never should have been brought at all
that the judge should not even send this
to a jury
that the witnesses have now essentially
testified to the innocent
of the of the that even the prosecution
witnesses are now testifying to the
innocence of kyle rittenhouse on the on
the self-defense defense
as ace of spades points out growth
screws drew out his gun and aimed it at
written house's head he did this as his
antifa confederate was swinging a large
skateboard at rittenhouse's head and
getting shot for that
in response to hoover pointing a gun in
his head written house aimed and fired
at him hit hoover in the arm it was a
devastating injury that ripped 90
percent of the muscle of his arm of his
bicep but gross cruz's testimony is even
more devastating for the prosecution
because again
there he is saying that um pointing a
gun at the
at the guy who shot him
yeah that's the and then the defense
attorney gets up and starts shouting
directed verdict okay so here's how the
media cover this because they have to
try to pretend that this is an actual
case this is the part that's
unbelievable
here is how the media covers this
okay the the media covered this this way
headline from cbs news lone survivor
shot by kyle rittenhouse at kenosha
protest testified he thought he was
going to die
here's the headline from the washington
post gage grosskroots says he feared for
his life before kyle rittenhouse shot
him during kenosha unrest here's the
daily beast the man who survived being
shot by kyle rittenhouse in kenosha
wisconsin last august testified on
monday he never tried to kill the
heavily armed teenager in fact he said
at the teen's murder trial he was
actually trying to surrender to him
okay and here is nbc news's takeaway
quote kyle written house shooting victim
says he thought he was going to die
okay so
i'm sorry but that's not the story the
story is that he admitted that he was
pointing a gun
at the defendant when the defendant shot
him
here's the opener from the new york
times however how it was covered quote
gage grosskroots the only person who
survived being shot by kyle written
house in kenosha wisconsin took the
witness stand on monday and described
the incidents he faced at mr rittenhouse
what was going through your head at this
particular moment said thomas binger the
prosecutor that i was going to die said
mr gross coots a volunteer paramedic
yeah that's that's yeah mm-hmm the
description there
and then here's where they get to the
point okay as the prosecution's case in
the homicide trial of mr rittenhouse
nears an end gross group 28 calmly
delivered for several hours as a star
witness for the state but his testimony
at times lent support to mr
rittenhouse's central claim that he was
acting in self-defense when he shot mr
gross croots and two other men
testimony underscored a broader
challenge for prosecutors
yeah you think you think
under cross-examination gross crew gave
testimony that suggested his role in the
events was complicated
like mr rittenhouse mr grosskroot was
armed that night and he was asked why he
had falsely told police detectives
shortly after the shooting that his
glock pistol had fallen out of his
holster that night rather than saying he
had pulled it as visual evidence showed
so he lied to the cops he told them the
reason his gun was out when they arrived
and he was you know holding his now gone
bicep
that when the reason his gun was out he
said it's because it fell out
except that on video he pulls out the
gun and he's raising it to point it at
the defendant
under questioning he acknowledged he was
carrying the gun concealed without a
valid permit
and that he had denied a request from
the police in september 2020 to
interview him about the shootings
corey shirafasi says when you were
standing as the lawyer for the defense
said so when you were standing three to
five feet from him with your arms up in
the air he never fired right correct mr
gross crews answered it wasn't until you
pointed your gun at him advanced on him
with your gun now your hands down
pointed at him that he fired correct
correct he said
and the headline is he thought he was
going to die
in what world is that the headline this
case is over it never should have been
brought but it demonstrates how
prosecutors their incentive structures
are such that they will bring faulty
prosecutions so long as they believe
that the left media want them to do so
that is hideous and ugly stuff we have
prosecutors across the country who are
being driven by the left-wing political
agenda not prosecuting actual crimes in
san francisco but prosecuting non-crimes
in kenosha wisconsin based on the whims
of the national media who then proceed
to cover up the actual facts of the case
in a wide variety of these cases man you
got a fear
acting in self-defense in a state where
the media have sway
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed